Energy!
What is it?
If something’s gonna cause an object to
move,
Whether tiny as a photon or as big as the
moon,
We can calculate how much movement that could
be,
And that number is a thing that we call energy.
(Energy, energy)
And it’s measured in Joules.
I don’t mean like precious jewels,
I mean like James Joule
It can be stored in stretched elastic or the
movement of a ball,
The repulsion of two magnets or the bonds
in chemicals,
Between the apple and the earth, if an apple
wants to fall,
The nuclei of atoms, mass of anything at all.
But whenever there’s a change we shifted
energy,
By pushing, heating, lighting or electricity.
It will go to a new store, that’s what we
observe,
‘Cos there’s a fundamental law that says
that energy’s conserved.
It can’t be made or destroyed!
(Energy, energy)
There’s many ways it is stored!
Change means it’s shifted to new stores.
And the energy after is the same as before.
So let’s think about the energy of gases
in a tin,
The particles are moving fast and bouncing
within,
The faster that they move, the hotter that
they are,
And a measure of their average speed is temperature.
And since particles attract that will store
energy too,
And means that it will take more work to make
the particles move,
So every substance has its own specific heat
capacity,
And different latent heat to change the state
it can be.
It can’t be made or destroyed!
(Energy, energy)
There’s many ways it is stored!
Change means it’s shifted to new stores.
And the energy after is the same as before.
So what’s power?
Power is how fast you can move the energy,
how many Joules every second, or Watts.
So if somebody asks you ‘Watts the unit
of power?’
You say ‘Yes it is!’
But in the real world, we find that energy
escapes,
Like when your coffee gets cold, that’s
why we insulate,
And air resistance and friction make cars
decelerate,
So they are aerodynamic and then we lubricate.
It can’t be made or destroyed!
(Energy, energy)
There’s many ways it is stored!
Change means it’s shifted to new stores.
And the energy after is the same as before.
It can’t be made or destroyed!
(Energy, energy)
There’s many ways it is stored!
Change means it’s shifted to new stores.
And the energy after is the same as before.